hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
Carty generation for identity purity and
potency assay testing presented by dr.
Tiye hexam field application scientist
cell therapy at Thermo Fisher Scientific
I'm Christie Joel of lab rats and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
for more information on our sponsor
please visit thermo Fisher comm now
let's get started I would like to remind
everyone that today's event is
interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type the minute e ask a question
box and click send also please notice
you can share this webinar on your
personal social media just click on the
social sharing tab to let your friends
and colleagues know about today's live
event if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on that
support tab down at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by using the ask a question box
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I now like
to introduce today's presenter dr. Tiye
hexam field application scientist
cell therapy for Thermo Fisher
Scientific for a complete biography on
our speaker please visit the biography
tab at the top of your screen
dr. hexam you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the introduction Christy
today I want to talk to you guys about
Carty generation for identity purity and
potency assay testing I really just want
to give an overview of some of the
characterization methods you guys can be
using when you're out there developing
these cool therapies that are happening
right now
so by the time you you know we've
finished presenting this slide I'm sure
these numbers will change they're
constantly changing but it's a it's a
really cool time to be in cell and gene
therapy with a lot of exciting
advancements that's happening so you
know lots of lots of things in clinical
trials there's seven approved
regenerative medicines already approved
the FDA and EMA are approving therapies
for car two therapies for the field of
oncology also lots of phase three trials
going on 100 132 right now so but we
still have a lot of challenges that
remain there's a complex supply chain
issue logistics of 150 or more vendors
that you might have to coordinate you
have to keep up with demand and capacity
issues how many patients do you think
you're going to have to treat how are
you going to meet that demand and then
there's still cytokine release syndrome
and some other neurological toxicity
risks what I really love about working
with thermo and and bringing you this
information is that we're really
uniquely positioned to help you in this
market and to make a significant impact
to help you with this because we've
taken some of these therapies from their
initial discovery stages all the way
through to commercialization and so
we're here and experienced in being able
to help you with that excuse me guys I
have a little bit of a cold so pardon my
part in my clearing my throat sometimes
so in cell and gene therapy there's a
there's a number of industry challenges
I'm going to go over a broad view of
this and then I really want to focus on
a few critical things so you have the
quality and logistics some of that stuff
that I talked about before
the speed of the innovation and it going
to market is very rapid at some of the
rapid most rapid timing we've seen the
cost it's still very expensive to do and
we're always trying to drive down the
cost of goods and there's a lot of
regulatory compliance and documentation
you really need to consider
during today's web webinar I'd really
like to focus on some of the advanced
analytical tools to help you with
defining your process and and the
product QC that you might do
so one thing that's really important to
understand when it comes to sewing gene
therapy is that we're defining the
process as much as we're defining this
cell therapy so while you're
manufacturing the cell therapy or the
the gene therapy depending on what
you're doing there's a lot of in process
monitoring and testing that occurs so
it's really yours your entire cell
therapy you're characterizing the
process as much as that endpoint like I
just just said so it's critical to be
able to understand and monitor the
therapy as you go throughout the process
itself as well as what your defined
release criteria is at the end when
you're administering it back into the
patient so I don't want you guys to I
also want to remind you that there's a
broader background of characterization
it's not just identity purity and
potency like we classically think about
it it also is manufacturing consistency
and safety which purities or impurities
do you have and these are really
important things to consider as well
don't just don't get too myopic and
focusing on the identity purity and
potency there's more to it like I said
because you know the recipe I make in my
kitchen if I'm going to use an analogy
of having a kitchen and a recipe for the
cell therapy the the way that I make a
specific recipe might be different from
the way you make a specific recipe and
so that's why we need to remember that
that whole process is something to
character it as well as the fact that
you know the end result might be quite
different as well
so how do we really look at these these
analytical tools and help to create them
and define them and bring them into
something that is what we'll be using to
define our our cell therapy in the end
so assays in general are developed in
stages so when you're in your
preclinical stages you're going to be
developing what is the assay what am i
measuring does this really work
by the time you're in phase one and
Phase two you're going to be really
developing it and seeing if it can stand
up to the eight qualities that are
important
and quality assays and that precision is
it precise is it accurate does it have a
limit of detection does it have a limit
of quantification is it specific for
what I'm measuring is it rugged is it
robust and is it linear and giving me
arrange a clear range so these are all
things that are really important to make
sure that you're actually measuring what
you intend to be measuring is your assay
fit for purpose by phase three of the
assay you should are by phase three of
your clinical trials you should have an
essay that is completely validated and
fit for purpose and what you know what
we mean when we say fit for purposes
isn't able to predict what it's really
measuring
so what we did here with our scientists
in the lab is we took a integrated
approach to make a cartoon there are
pieces to do some of these measurement
tools to really validate what what it is
that we have that we sell on the market
too so we we started with PBMCs we did
an untouched isolation using our
dynabeads
we did a CD 3t cell isolation this is a
important because we're making car
cheese here and so with those car keys
we we then put them in in culture excuse
me in culture for a couple of days with
our cts cgo china bees for activation of
the t-cells as well as using our
optimizer and immune cell serum
replacement as the Culture Media after a
couple of days we expose them to Lenti
virus which was created in our c GSLV
maxvill into viral production system and
what this lentivirus is doing I'll
remind you guys who are a little bit new
to the car to work slow polenta virus is
doing a genetic editing and inserting a
car and these cars are used for fighting
different diseases
so the commercialized one right now our
blood cancers but a lot of the
researchers out there are doing lots of
different kinds of cool stuff with gene
editing these tools so we just took a
really simple car using the LV and then
after after we did the transduction and
gene editing of the car into the T cell
we then expanded them with CTS optimizer
l-glutamine glutimax il-2 I mean cell
serum replacement and grew those up for
five to ten days so this is typically a
process that lasts one to two weeks
based on the methodology or the recipe
that you use em in your lab or in your
manufacturing facility and and although
there's a general workflow so there's a
lot of nuances and differences between
the different therapies that are on the
market and being developed and so I just
want to highlight a couple of broad
areas where quantification is required
and where you can think about some of
the analytical solutions that you can be
using throughout this
you know I'll go into more detail with
these but cell line Ascenta fication
identity and purity potency microbial
testing and viral safety are all
analytical solutions that you'll want to
consider as you're going throughout this
entire process so of the experiments
that we ran in the lab and the cars that
we made we made it in three different
donors and the first thing we wanted to
do is make sure that the cells we
started with in the cells we ended with
came from the same donor one of the
largest costs when it comes to the
manufacturing of a commercial product is
making sure that what you you start with
an end with are the same patient
obviously you don't want to treat
somebody with somebody else's cells
right so here's a simple tool that you
can use so one of the reasons why it's
most expensive is because there's been a
lot of auction put into play with making
you know one patient per one
manufacturing room in the GMP suite but
here's another alternative - part of
that safety and that's a molecular tool
used to make sure that the patient you
started with and the patient you ended
with are the same patient so as you can
see here we used our applied Biosystems
identify our PCR amplification kit this
is an str based methodology it looks at
multiple Louis ID to identify multiple
donors for each other and make to
differentiate them and to make sure that
what you started with is what you added
with using the DNA fingerprinting of the
donor that contributed the material this
is the same technology that's used in
human identification and criminal labs
so this is the first thing that we did
to make sure that we were analyzing and
looking at ourselves in the correct way
and another thing that I'd like to talk
to you about now is about immune cell
phenotype so identity and purity
assessment of immune cells there was a
workshop that was held and looked at the
characterization of cell products and
where is the need what are we doing
where is the need for improvement so as
you can see on the right-hand side of
this slide there was a large response of
needing improvement in cell count and
viability functional
on tests such as potency assay and in
vitro differentiation as well as flow
cytometry so we have these standard
workhorses that have been part of the
part of the solution for a long time but
the there's also this consensus that we
we need to be improving some of these
tools as well so I'm going to get into a
few of the challenges that exist in flow
cytometry for example so flow cytometry
is still the workhorse method it's still
the most utilizing gold standard and it
has some advantages and disadvantages
and so I want to talk to you today about
what those advantages are why we might
consider using flow and why we might
consider adopting a new a new technology
of looking at molecular immune
phenotyping our immune assessment and
characterization of ourselves so flow is
is great because it's got the gold
standard however the challenge is that
the antibodies how the antibodies are
made and how they're available can
create a problem sometimes you need to
do bridging studies between lots of
antibodies so if I measure I measure the
10 patients between January and June and
they use this lot of antibody let me
make sure that the next plot of antibody
comes out is an accurate control for
June through December right so you have
to do a bridging study and make sure
that the antibodies you use are
providing consistent results so you
don't get variability in the that most
critical data that you need to analyze
and that's the patient response it can
be very difficult to train and and bring
bring people on that that know and are
comfortable with utilizing this tool so
it takes a lot of training and you know
back when I worked in the lab we
sometimes we would have one sample and
three of us would run the same sample
and get quite different results
so it can be difficult and subjective on
on how these these results come out and
so that's a challenge too especially if
you're doing clinical trials where you
have different labs measuring these same
same metrics so you know lab to lab
comparison or
person-to-person comparison can be
difficult as well also sometimes you
might need to stimulate the cells too in
order for the markers to be able to see
them and if you're doing any kinds of
surface antigens that are not abundantly
expressed on the target shells or if you
have residual expression on control
cells there may be difficulty in
rendering the clear separation for your
flow additionally some of the new cell
therapies that are coming out are using
therapeutic antibodies in the end part
of the treatment as well and so that can
also make it not as clear of a result
when you're when you're looking at these
things so with that I'm going to I'm
going to talk to you about the flow
tools that we have that can help with
that standard workhorse method and then
in a couple of slides I want to show you
a new tool that's really exciting that
we have that can help with some of these
pain points that I've just described
described to you but in future Jen we
have B bioscience which is a is a
wonderful we have wonderful history of
having really good flow antibodies that
are validated and consistent they have
good quality and chemistry and standard
behind it and so what we did is we
wanted to make this a little bit simpler
for people in the in the party workflow
or people doing T regs or other kinds of
immune phenotypes we wanted to give them
a flow panel that would make it easy to
run things to reduce some of the
variability so have proven performance
make sure you have a highly referenced
antibody we have a number of different
references that are associated with this
so it gives you confidence in the
results and we wanted to really provide
a turnkey kit and protocol so with these
genotyping kits we we have a couple of
different times we have one for CD three
we have 140 reg and we have lunch for
th17 and so these panels come with pre
pre packed antibodies that give you the
typical flow that you might want to see
and so we did this on our car t-cells we
use this same cell phenotype in kit so
as you can see here in this in the
couple of the donors that we tested
you can see the the data that we
achieved so we have cd3 on the left hand
side you have the cd4 cd8 ratio we're
looking at the you know the night the
stemness or the night naiveness of the
cells with CD 62 l ccr7
and in the third set of graphs and then
we're also looking at the ice ax type in
the last set of graphs and that's just
really showing that I have a good
quality negative control so as you can
see we have a really nice standard flow
panel that makes it easy for you to have
some more consistency between between
labs and we also provide gating
strategies and some of the tools that
you'll need to make sure that you feel
confident that you're running something
consistent between the groups in your
lab so as I promised you I also want to
talk to you about a cool tool that we
can look at the that immune cell type
using a molecular based method so we
have a new tool in a partnership with
epi honest using applied using our
applied Biosystems CTS pure quant a fake
hints and this is a a really cool new
new PCR based tool that gives you a lot
more consistency between what some of
the challenges are when it comes to flow
so this gives you first of all you don't
have to have fresh fresh product so when
you're at the end of your 12 de kere a
guys elation process you don't have to
spend another two hours in the lab or
you know if you have a different if
you're working with car to use what have
you you don't have to spend those extra
couple hours in the lab you can freeze
the sample and it also makes it easier
for doing analysis between different
clinical trial sites so you have that
ability to not have to work with live
tissue it's a molecular based assay so
it gives you better results for
quantification and I'll go a little bit
more into that in a minute it helps with
regulatory filing as well it's developed
an adherence of the IC h q to our one
guideline that have the eight levels of
validation that I talked to you about
when it comes to validating assays and
of course you still need to validate it
that it's fit for
purpose but it's a great tool for
looking at the epigenetics of the immune
cells that are being used in your lab so
let's talk more about exactly how this
is working so there was a long time of
validating this process and we can go
more into that on the side we can talk
about that on the side down in this
webinar but what's really cool about
this is these pure quant assays are
taking the phenotype so instead of in
flow you're measuring the receptor on
the surface and this one we're going to
measure the unmethylated demethylation
of specific DNA in yourself so we all
have all cells have the same DNA right
and depending on how that DNA is
expressed you know translate it
translated transcribed and expressed in
yourself depends on how your cell will
perform so that's the cool thing about
this tool is it's looking at that that
recipe and saying in the specific place
the DNA is unmethylated therefore the
DNA is being transcribed and actively
expressed and so that's going to give me
a clear indication of the cell phenotype
and so the way that we can utilize this
this biological mechanism of
unmethylated with DNA when it's being
expressed is we have we're utilizing a
by self ID conversion so in your and
your DNA is the ones that are
unmethylated will have a C and the
methylated will have a c2 but when we do
the by sulphide conversion that allows
us to get the resolution that we need to
show the specific areas that are being
expressed and so in this kit here if
it's unmethylated it'll become a U and
if it's methylated it'll remain a C and
that has to do with a the methylation
that's that's being expressed so based
on this you can tell if the DNA is open
and being transcribed and then get a
better phenotype so I mean this I'll be
honest spent a lot of time developing
what that signature was for these immune
cell types that it took development and
years of validation but what's cool is
we now have that
tool so that we can utilize it to look
at the immune cell expression that's
happening in the population of cells
that we have made into cars so in our
three donors that we utilized for this
the purpose of this webinar we we
examine CD three cd4 cd8 T rig to 17
b-cells and monocytes so there are
articles out there that talk about
b-cells and monocytes being common
contaminate errs in the car to product
and so this is a way for us to look at
can we get the resolution we want and so
you can see here the quantification of
the expression of those different cell
populations and our donors but let's
just dig a little bit deeper here so
excuse me for a moment
so the way that we wanted to so what I
want to explain to you is that this is
designed for release testing so it comes
with some of those remember that eight
qualities that I talked to you about a
couple of slides back that are important
for validation and making sure that the
assay that you're making utilizing has
been examined and fit for purpose for
you so some of the designs that are
important in using those excuse me
analytical tools is to make sure you
have calibrations does does it correct
for the cue PCR assay specific
performance so like between
the time when I ran it on Monday and the
time I ran it on Friday am I getting
something consistent I need a calibrator
make sure I'm measuring with the same
measuring stick you'll need a reference
to check for the assay performance
making sure that this my assay working
today and then you'll want to standard
so the standard is there to help you
determine the copy number so what's
really cool about the methylation tool
as we know that there's a certain amount
of DNA places where this is expressed
and so this gives us a clear mechanism
for quantifying the number of cells that
are actually in the population measured
so one of the other things that's really
important that I talked to you about on
the earlier slide is making sure that
you have a limit of blank a limit of
detection and a limit of quantification
so what we did in our lab is we prepared
the standard DNA ask for the protocol
then we serially diluted it with 40 20
10 5 copies in blank then we took 10
replicate replicates of each of these
data points to really assure ourselves
that we we have the ability to measure
what we think we're measuring the limit
of blank obviously we want to see a
consistent zero there because it's blank
we don't want anything to show up there
limit of detection would be the bottom
number that we are confident in and the
limit of quantification would be where
we're confident 95% confidence that this
is the the range that we can detect in
our sample population so in addition to
that so you have all those references
and quality standards that make it a
good analytical tool we also wanted to
show
the you know the differences between
slow and what happened when you use the
qpcr methods that we're describing here
with the pure corn and so really cool I
love the study that they created here
that what they did is they're going to
spike in a number of contaminants and so
they have we have a million cells in our
sample here and that we either spiked in
a hundred thousand 50 thousand ten
thousand or zero of the contaminating
population and then the two the two
people in the lab analyzed this one with
flow and one with pure quant not talking
to each other at the same time and then
compared results at the end and so in
this spike in experiment you can see on
the bottom left graph where we have our
standard curve and see the nice
linearity that you would expect being
able to what you can be able to detect
and then you're comparing it to your
housekeeping gene gap pH there and the
flow cytometry it was really difficult
for that member of our lab to to
carefully gate and make sure that he was
confident and what his analysis was what
his results were and so some of the
results you know when you're getting
over to the right hand side so we're I'm
in the top graphs here in the flow graph
if you go to the right hand side when
you're at point eight five percent most
of people I know that run flow there
they're not going to feel confident in a
result like that right and so there's
there's a limit of where your confidence
is going to be when it comes to this
flow gating and so but what's really
cool is you did that gating and then our
qpcr analyst did the analysis using our
pure quant
and they got really similar results but
what's what's different about the pure
quant is we feel very confident because
we have specific copy numbers that we
can you can utilize there so we feel
very confident in those results and so
you can see when we expect in ten
percent of contaminating B cells we got
around you know six point three six
point five percent read back and and
vice versa and so that gives you a lot
of
confidence in the in the test itself as
well as showing you some of the pluses
and minuses of using the two different
ones the two different metrics here for
analysis
so when it comes to what you think about
when you're trying to decide between
flow or qPCR based methods there's a
couple of things to think about you know
so if you're using flow you might want
when it comes to flow you'd want to
think about you know when you're casting
a wide net if you think I'm not exactly
sure how the drug that I'm developing is
modulating the immune system so I'm
going to cast a wide net I'll use
multiple flow panels to reduce so that I
can see what my specific signature is or
if you have receptor occupancy that you
want to see the particular cell surface
marker and how many of them have been
engaged or if you want to see a change
in activation state with something
phosphorylated or a specific protein
utilized those are times when flow is
very advantageous on the other hand when
it comes to the epigenetic immune cell
quantification you would want to
consider using the pure corn assay for
precise quantification and depletion or
reconstitution of specific cell types
especially if you've been using
depleting antibodies you'll want to
utilize it for immune phenotyping for a
large number of samples and then immune
cell profiling when they have solid
tissues so if extraction of viable cells
is particularly challenging like in a
solid tumor excuse me you would want to
utilize this because you don't have to
have the live cells so pure quant would
be really advantageous for that
component as well also immune cell
profiling when you have multiple centers
and multiple sites where you're doing
this this has allowed you to have many
remote locations and have you know
isolation and shipment to have it all
run in the same place or you can have
consistency between the labs together so
with that I'm going to I'm going to
transition now to move on to another
assay that's utilized in the Carty there
if you workflow and that's a functional
assay which really looks at that the car
cheese I made were are they able to sell
to kill their target cell population so
here we made the car cheese according to
the workflow I told you about earlier
and we expose them so these cars are
against have a cd19 for their
and so they're going to attack a CB 19
expressing cells so we had k562 cells in
co culture with them expressing CD 19
and when these these cells are exposed
to each other if the car key is
functional and working us I hope it
should be after I've spent all this time
culturing them it will kill the cell and
start to lyse it and in that lie sing
and killing of the cell you'll have
release of lactate dehydrogenase or LD h
when that LD h is expressed we can then
monitor that and measure that as a
something that shows the functional
killing so typically you do different
ratios of your car to your ear cancer
mimicking cell here which is cd19 k562
and you can see that the cars that we
made had they did effectively kill the
k562 cells and this is another assay
that we have here at thermo Fisher for
you to analyze that so when these car
keys are killing one of the ways that
they kill is with cytokines and
chemokines and so a lot of times what
I've seen in the and the publications
and the articles out there with what's
going on in South therapy is that we're
finding specific phenotypes and and
fingerprints characterizing this the
cell types that are being made because
there's a lot of things going into it is
my self functional are they potent can
they kill but how long are they
persisting - and so some of the
responders that they're seeing in the
patient populations and non-responders
they're looking at a lot of these these
assays to see if they can find specific
fingerprints for why it worked or why it
didn't work and so one of the other ways
you might want to do that is by looking
at the specific cytokines and chemokines
fingerprint that the cells that you're
creating or making and so we have an in
beiträge in cytokines and chemokines 34
Plex human protocol music art a black
panel using the luminix platform
using guys that's of course no one plans
on getting sick for their webinar right
but excuse me why so by looking at this
you can really identify this specific
cytokines that have been released into
the media so what happens is we exposed
so sorry for the busyness of the panel
but I just want to really show you
finger printing here so we're exposing
the card to use to the cd19 k562 cells
we're incubating it for 16 hours and
then using the lumen xs8 and looking at
the supernatant we're going to look at
what those specific fingerprints are for
the cell types that we came up with are
they affect yourselves are they
stimulatory are the chemo attractive or
are they regulatory and so as you can
see here we did that readout for our car
key donors to see what their specific
signature was when in agreement so I've
talked to you a lot some of the ways
that we can look at the identity some of
the ways we can look at purity in some
of the ways we can look at functionality
some of those early tools that I talked
to you about for the tools that we can
use but I also want to talk to you about
you know contamination in in your assay
so how do I make sure that what I've
been manufacturing I don't know if you
have a closed or an open system that
you're working with over there chances
are you have a little bit of a mix you
want to make sure that the cells that
you've made are safe to go back into the
patient so one of the the common
contaminations that we want to look for
is mycoplasma
and so a thermo Fisher we have the
applied Biosystems micro sneak
mycoplasma detection kit so this is a
regulatory accepted method it's been
accepted in EMEA and fda with a number
of different tissue cells gene therapy
and vaccines that are already using this
as an approved method for testing
mycoplasma in the excuse me in the
culture so typically in the past before
this is available and approved you would
have to spend 28 days and in culture
having your mycoplasma being expressed
and then you test it later but when you
have a living drug like we do in some of
these therapies you don't have 28 days
besides the fact that sometimes in the
atala get cell therapy so patients are
really sick they might not have another
28 days to wait for that for that drug
to be cleared and approved so we set out
to look for a way that we could give you
the results in
and your results to make sure you don't
have mycoplasma contamination and as
little as five hours so we took that
that pain point of waiting for 28 days
and made it into an essay that you can
run in five hours and so this detection
kit we ran it on ourselves of course to
confirm that the cells the cartoons that
we made in the lab were negative for
mycoplasma as you can see on the right
over here so there's 90 different
strains and species that are a part of
the kit where on the right hand table
you can see that all of the cars that we
made were negative and so this is just
giving us another assurance that the
product that we made you know we had the
identity we had the purity of it we had
the functionality as a killing we had
the fingerprinting of the chemo kind in
that cytokines being used and now we're
looking at is it something that's safe
do I have contamination no there's no
micro plasma contamination so I hope
that I've given you some some of the
tools that are useful for that broad
overview for when you're manufacturing
cars for atala gist therapies I'm going
to pivot and transition a little bit to
talk about some of the newer stuff
that's useful when it comes to
allogeneic as well as atala ggest so the
part of the workflow that I focused on
kind of broad because you know we're all
making different recipes in our kitchen
I was talking a little bit specifically
about atala guess there's another
another version of making cars which is
allergenic so part some of the pain
points that exist as Atala Gaston the
patient and going back into the patient
sometimes these patients are quite sick
and they don't have a there so t-cells
don't always expand so that was one of
the most recent things that I was
reading in a publication is depending on
the expansion of the car sometimes that
would predict or indicate if there was
going to be a response or non-responder
to the treatment additionally sometimes
they're not healthy enough to even get
leukapheresis and so you might have to
have a change in your raw material to
use whole blood instead of a leuco pack
so there's a number of different
challenges besides the cost can also be
very expensive if you're making a
bespoke treatment for the patient
so this atala ggest so people have been
looking at alginate can I take a healthy
donor can I
can I remove some of the dangers that
exist like graft-versus-host disease
rejection different stuff like that can
I make car t-cells from that and have
something that's an off-the-shelf
product ready to go so the minute that
you know somebody gets diagnosed that
they can have this available as the
treatment that they can receive almost
immediately rather than waiting those
two weeks and in addition I talk to you
a little bit about the cost of goods so
attalia since it's a therapy that's the
spokes specifically for that person you
have a higher cost of goods and then if
you have a failure in your manufacturing
process you fail to treat that patient
so that's another another deterrent or
disadvantage to using Atalla ggest era P
in alginate you know you can see the
cost of good calculation that was done
here you can see the reference below
they say estimates that because you can
make it in a bigger batch and do more
validation and stuff like that and have
it ready off the shelf to go that you
can drive the cost of goods down quite
dramatically to be less than 5,000
floors and dose compared to ninety five
ninety six thousand dollars to dose so I
want to talk to you a little bit about
this emerging trend and some other tools
we have that might contribute to
characterization if you're thinking
about allergenic as the workflow that
you're working with so one of the
emerging trends when it comes to the a
low genetic t-cell is taking a t-cell
taking blood cells from the donor making
them into induced pluripotent stem cells
doing genetic editing either sometimes
it's to remove MHC class you know
sometimes it's to remove mm and make
them only Express cars there's different
different strategies out there but gene
editing nonetheless so Gina at the
t-cells
oh I'm sorry the plumber potent stem
cells and then take those and
differentiate them back into C cells and
inject them into a patient and so we
have a number of different tools that
can be utilized in this whole workflow
as you can see them listed over here on
the left I'm going to talk to you really
high-level about it and how you might be
thinking about using these tools if this
is one of the emerging trends that
you're looking at or investigating so
the first thing that you need to do
besides some of the tools that I've
talked to you about before like making
sure that the cells you start with are
the cells you end with one of the things
that's really important is reprogram do
you have a mechanism for reprogramming
that doesn't leave us a fingerprint or a
footprint of the reprogramming mechanism
and is it something that's safe so we
have this I know tune 2.0 which is our
research youth only kit we developed a
CTS sight attune 2.1 and this is using
Sendai virus as a reprogramming
mechanism that commute that you can
utilize to do the footprint free
reprogramming I have a whole nother
webinar on that that I dive into it much
deeper so if you'd like to hear more
about that please consult that webinar
what's important about this is that we
we know that you can reprogram a number
of different cells so we we have
workflows to help you with t-cells cd34
or fiberglass depending on what your
starting cell population is
one of the ways that we made the site
attuned to point one a safer safer tool
for during the pluripotency induction or
the reprogramming is we replaced emic
with elm ik we removed any animal
components and we make sure that it's
manufactured in a GMP facility we've
also done some work in-house to look at
how can you kind of play with some of
the protocols for making T cells are
induced pluripotent cells from T cells
and we've seen that hypoxic conditions
actually help drive efficiency of the
reprogramming up we compared laminin
versus Vautrin nekton we also did a
little bit of work on you know looking
at if my t-cells are exhausted if I have
higher expression of exhaustion in the t
cell markers I actually interestingly
get a higher reprogramming efficiency
for that we also looked at is there a
difference between if I do negative
isolation versus positive isolation
didn't see a really big change there but
we did see a little bit increase if you
have positive isolation cells so this is
just some of the work that we've done
in-house to support you would this be a
tool that you'd want to use what's
really great about this as well as we
have the Sendai quantification kit so I
told you you'd want to make sure that
when you're doing this induction this
reprogramming that you'd want to make
sure it's something that doesn't leave a
footprint over time so that it's that
Sendai virus or that virus that you used
to do that no longer exists when when
you have the cells that you're going to
be utilizing for making your therapy
downstream and injecting back into the
human so we've taken some of the PBMCs
that we made into IPS even measured the
Sendai virus expression so as you can
see on the bottom left after passage
four six and ten we have complete
removal of the of the footprint of that
Sendai virus and so you can have good
can you can have good confidence that
you've removed the IPS D inducing Sendai
virus to make sure that you're you're
safe and that you can go on to utilize
them for what you have planned for the
therapy downstream
so if you're doing what I talked about
where you're taking t-cells you might
also want to do a couple of others tool
so we've talked about this in a
different webinar so you might confirm
pluripotency karyotyping safety and
identity which I'll briefly go over just
to remind you this but I really want to
focus on how you might also want to look
at the immune repertoire and the HLA
typing and the uncle uncle mine kinetic
screen so when you're making PSD banks
you want to make sure that you're
testing the identity purity and
suitability throughout the process so
after you do the induction you know when
you saw them make sure that you have all
the robustness of the quality assays
that we talked about before do you have
specificity linear linearity range
accuracy precision and is it something
that has limited detection limit on
blank living um quantification and so
the qualification of PSC cell banks
that's really important and we provide
for you through different quantitative
are three different tools molecular
based tools to do that and like I said
we've talked about this before so I just
want to give you a brief overview you
want to make sure that the cells that
you've reprogrammed are actually
pluripotent so we have a pleura test can
which is a machine learning model of
pluripotency based on global
transcriptome assay that's a highly
validated tool and something that you
can use to make sure that the so that
you created or poor fulton you wanna
also want to make sure that the cells
you've created have the ability to
differentiate in the cell you want we
have the scorecard panel it's a 93 gene
expression assay with simple views cause
cloud-based data analysis software and
that'll just show you yes I can make all
the different three the three different
lineage potential if I differentiate
downstream you'll also want to make sure
that you have genomic stability so we
have digital karyotyping and genotyping
in a single assay with cario stat or
carry off that HD a say available for
for these sorts of things in addition I
want to talk to you a little bit about
the TCR
bata profiling so one thing we found
when we were taking T cells and
reprogramming them we found that we
actually got a population we were
surprised about this we got a population
of cells that were not showing to be T
cells arrived so we found it to be
really important as we continue to do
this work to to look at if we had TCR if
we really had clonal liminal populations
that we had picked and so what we've
done here is we have the donor T cells
on the top the top left you can see
we've looked at the TC TCR beta so the T
cell receptor beta genotype showing a
heterogeneous you know T cells that are
present and then from there when you're
making your clones you'll want to pick
one that's a homogenous clone and so you
know on the bottom left you can see a
cone that was derived from a homogenous
tool and so of you know approximately
what was surprising for us was
approximately a third of the T cell
derived IPS these were not T cell
derived another third were non clonal
and then another third were clonal and
so you want to do the sequencing and we
think it's critical to ensure that you
have the clonal population of T cell
induced pluripotent stem cells and so
that might be another really important
test for you to to make sure that the
clone that you have is has a TCR and
it's homogeneous in nature yep that's
another critical component you might
think about as well in addition to this
some of the things that are important
when it comes to a low genetic work is
you might want to have some HLA
profiling that happens so you can get
graft-versus-host disease if you have
HLA incompatibility like I said some
people have different strategies some
people are erasing this completely with
their gene editing some people are
trying to match it from donors there
there are strategies out there for doing
bone marrow transplant but saving some
of the HSC s from here and making cars
from the HSC s so there's a number of
different strategies that are being used
out there in the cell therapy world but
we want to give you
you know a kit that you can use to
really look at the HLA profiling as well
and so we have a link seek HLA kit and
this will give you the low resolution
two digit qPCR HLA typing so as you can
see from some of the cells that we made
we either made from a fibroblast or from
a t-cell that we had matching HLA typing
for ourselves
there isn't so that really gives us not
matching excuse me but that gives us an
idea of what kind of HLA typing is there
and so that helps us know you know it's
the donor cells and the IPS P derivative
if they have the same HLA typing or say
you want to treat allogeneic somebody
else you that gives you a lot of
information on what might be a good
mechanism for making sure you have the
matching there you might also want to
check for cancer hotspots so we have an
uncle mine comprehensive so after you've
done some of this reprogramming you want
to make sure that you don't have that
you haven't induced cancer hotspots some
of the risk that's happened in the past
is different gene gene therapies or gene
editing is that there was concerns about
uncle uncle genic genetic mutations and
so what we've done is we also offer an
alkaline comprehensive assay to make
sure that you don't have any hot spots
when you're doing this genetic editing
and manipulation so I hope that I've
shown you in today's webinar a couple of
different things I hope I've shown you
how you can think about some of the
tools we have for at Auguste therapy
some of the tools we have for if you're
going down the allergenic or out some
things that we've learned in the lab
that we would caution you and suggest
that you think about using is quality
and then you know overall I also just
want to give you a larger overview of
the products and assays that are
designed for translation I promised you
at the beginning that thermo Fisher is
uniquely positioned to help you in this
and part of the way that we're really
positioned to help you in this is based
on the quality that we really bring to
the table and so we want to give you
assets that are consistent and
high-quality reliable and scalable
supply
so we prequalify our product you have 21
CFR compliance iso 13485
so that helps to reduce the amount of
time and resources that you need to do
when it comes to material qualification
when you're applying for regulatory
support we also want to focus on
characterization and safety we have a
comprehensive and scalable
characterization extensive QC testing
for safety and and you'll think about
those kinds of things when when you're
working with yourself and then we also
want to provide you with platforms that
are easy translation so we have a lot of
products that you're easy to use from
research youth only into the CTF
branding which is more for the
regulatory support you need when it
comes to filing for cell and gene
therapy approval and so when you do
transition to that CGS branding we are
able to offer you documentation and
support when it comes to that so drug
master file certificate of origin
certificate analysis those types of
things so talk to your sales rep or your
representative that's in your area about
the products that you can use that are
are you--oh to cts easy translation for
you
you know a lot of the tools that I
talked to you about today they're kind
of complex and a little bit daunting
it's like well Tia I don't know if I can
really put the resources out there to
bring some of these Co efficient or
cause qualitative tools into my into my
lab I don't I don't want to buy the
instrument I don't want to spend the
time to get somebody up and running on
this is there any way that you can help
me in another way and the answer to that
is yes we can if you if you don't want
to have some of these services or some
of these tools in your lab but you want
to run some of these tests we do have
the option to help you with custom
services so we have that when it comes
to viral services cell model cell
engineering and assay development and
there's a there's a number of things
listed there lots of lots of cool
exciting tools so if some of this seems
like it's too much to bring on but you
still want to run it for for your
information uses or how have you talked
to us we're here to support you with
those custom services as well and as I
do love to remind
that I talked to about this you know
thermo Fisher is able to do all of this
stuff because we innovate with a
partnerships with you guys we're only
able to offer these tools a lot of them
have been developed in collaboration
with people outside an outside of
industry and so we want to partner with
you to create next-generation
technologies as well as to help build
commercial infrastructure for those
people that are getting closer to
commercialization so we're here to
partner with you we want to partner with
you thank you so much for your time and
attention and with that I'll pause and
and ask for any questions thank you for
your time
thank you dr. hexam for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of our webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now just click on that ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we will answer as many
questions as we have time for okay let's
get started
that's a hexam our first question is how
safe is the use of lentivirus during the
modification of t-cells into car keys
well that's a great question so safety
is one of those things that you
definitely need to be thinking about
when you're working in cell therapy and
developing that so what's what's really
interesting is immune cells they are
made they're a part of our body and
they're supposed to be fighting anything
that naturally edit their genes like
viruses and so in the past t-cells are
so robust and not being edited that it
wasn't until HIV came around that we
found something that could effectively
edit t-cells and so
HIV was the first time that we saw that
you could genetically program to cells
although in nature with HIV was for for
a bad thing
and so but part of what we learned
during the process of learning about HIV
and trying to cure it because we learn
different molecular mechanisms and tool
to like pieces of the gene tool editing
that we could then hijack and and
utilize for a purposeful good use right
and so what we came up with is three
different generations of taking pieces
of that that machinery that we know that
they were effectively using and making
that just something that we could use
for the pet and so lentivirus the
current antivirus that's mostly used is
a third generation where we take
different components of different things
from nature that naturally gene edit T
cells so viruses and what-have-you many
different viruses and we take the
components of the machinery that that we
know that we can utilize to hijack that
that that gene editing and put that into
the T cell and so you know third
generation we're trying to make it safer
and so one of the things that they've
done with the machinery is make it so I
can't rougher replicate itself and make
more virus in the future and so that's
one of the safety mechanisms they use
there's also different mechanisms that
people are looking into to get away from
viruses completely so whether that be
electroporation giving an electric shock
to disrupt the cell membrane or other
other types of
ways to Ginette it as well so CRISPR is
another thing that you'll see out there
but there's a there's many different
ways that you can edit the car cheese
and that are being investigated and
lentiviruses the classic one because it
was so the one that we finally found the
machinery necessary to be able to edit
these really robust cell types because
you know the ones that are supposed to
fight should never be you know impacted
by the things that they're fighting but
we were able to hijack that machinery
here
dr. hexam our next question which of the
products covered is CTS grade versus rul
okay that's a great question so what
we've done in a lot of our development
for the tools that we have provided for
you so some of the products I showed you
are are you only option and some of that
just has to do with that that you need
to validate them as fit for purpose or
they might be more useful for in
informational use only so can a lot of
what's happening is you're defining this
process you're delivering the treatment
but don't forget about the part of
monitoring the patient's and going back
to the drawing board so I only talked to
you about the top half of the circle
there's a whole nother bottom half of
the circle where after we've delivered
the treatment we're still learning and
we're still going back to you know
version 2 version 3 versions four of
these cell therapies and so for
informational use only is also a
powerful tool when it comes to that the
easiest way for you to fix if the
product is research use only or CTS
grade really has to do with like the law
we have it's a limited use liability
license how can I use this or if you
have a CTS branding on the product
itself the CCS branding is for that
signifies that it's 21 CFR compliant and
then it has all that documentation that
I talked to you about in the second to
last slide before the end and then you
know if you're really if you're really
wondering if it comes down to it you
just just write to our tech support and
they can help support you with this but
but for the most part everything that I
presented to you is is is intended for
using in South air if you whether it be
for informational you Sony or or
something else and so hopefully our
branding there is clear and helps you
distinguish but more than happy for us
to have that conversation on the side
too if you have specific questions about
specific products
hexam if send my virus views in the
Saito tune reprogramming kit safe to use
and cell therapy and does it alter the
host genome
that's a really great question so one of
the cool things about Sendai virus is it
doesn't integrate into the genome and so
that's one of the ways that it is a
safer tool and mechanism to use for
inducing clear potent stem cell for for
reprogramming
here so and that's also I presented you
that piece of information that you can
measure the footprint test is gone so
the sentence while it's in there it's
going to help reprogram the cells but
then after throughout the passages it
dilutes out and so that's why it's
really great to have that additional
tool to show that the Sendai virus is
completely gone from from the cells
before you go on to utilize them for
other purposes def or whatever your
downstream workflow is that's a good
question
thank you dr. hexton no it looks like
we're out of time do you have any final
comments for our audience
no I just want to thank you guys so much
for attending the webinar I hope I was
able to answer some questions that not
please give us those questions and the
and the submission that you have there I
think it's a really important thing for
us to discuss this when it comes to
characterization of the T cells and the
cell therapy product there's so much for
us to learn together and there's still
so much to do in this field and so let's
continue the conversation together
submit those questions contact your
thermo Fisher people reach out on
LinkedIn we want to continue to have
this conversation thank you so much for
being a part of the webinar we really
appreciate it
and thank you dr. hexam before Rico I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
question those questions we were not
able to answer today and those that are
submitted during the on-demand period
will be answered by dr. hexam and her
team via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration I'd
like to once again thank dr. Tiye hexam
for time today and I'd also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor
Thermo Fisher Scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand and
labret swil alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now and we
hope to see you again soon have a great
day